Fabi in our eyes a very tense match so
far between yourself and Ray how would
you describe it up to this point yeah
well it had didn't have so much content
the first game had had some content for
sure
but I didn't really get many chances and
in fact I think he was the one who had
probably a better position at some point
the opening wasn't really a success so
it was more based on surprise value but
he knew it uh more intimately than I had
hoped and today Ray took a decision
um to go to a wrap the rapid playoff
rather than try to press and potentially
make it a three result game
I mean I knew that this was an option I
wasn't sure what his mindset would be if
he wanted to do this or if you wanted to
to play a full game and uh and see what
happens
but but it's certainly a strategy I mean
I I think were you ready for it
well there's not much to be ready for
like if he wants to draw it was I was
wasn't opposed to the idea
I was ready for the possibility let's
say but you can't prepare
um
let's say for a drawing unless you're
really trying to press for winning black
and I didn't feel like like that was a
necessity
so um yeah I was more like trying to
figure out ways that he would try to
outplay me the opening or again imagine
the opening not that he would try to
clean up the game because
that's just you know we'll go to Rapid
and see what happens a big point of
discussion has the has been this balance
between the time formats you play
classical then you play rapid maybe
Blitz maybe even Armageddon are you
ready for that how do you get ready for
those type of situations and I think
we're really used to it because a lot of
events have a mix of different time
controls and especially 10 minute is
quite um
quite in fashion these days like okay
it's played here with the five second
increment but also there's a lot of
online events where it's played with a
two second agreement and last year there
was also a lot of online inventors
played Without increment
so we have yeah slightly different types
of time controls but but the spirit
Remains the Same I mean rap it has its
own set of let's say Necessities
compared to classical chess and Blitz is
of course even even more different and
Armageddon is a whole other thing which
still we're getting used to I think a
lot of players because it's not so
common but
um but I have to say like in the last
let's say two years three years I
probably played more Armageddon than in
my entire career before that potentially
a long match ahead of yourself what are
you going to do for the next three hours
are we going to get some rest are you
going to train look at his openings
what's the schedule probably a mix of
all of that and and also keep an eye on
the games that are in progress but yeah
some some prep some strategy and and
some rest as well as important guys any
questions yeah quick question for you
February uh the conjecture of my
colleague Jovi it's not me this is Jovi
She said in game one after you played
the move H4 that Queen H5 was you you
messed up your preparation you intended
to play Queen G4 is what she said
choices Queen G4 we were confused by age
four and queen H5 what explain that so
the Box stops with Jovi exactly
so so I can I H4 was sort of preparation
but A6 I wasn't ready for I didn't know
uh the nuances of that compared to A5
which I thought was a bit more natural
to push the pawn a bit farther
and after A5 I was going to play Queen
H5 after A6 I I figured there's probably
some differences of the B5 Bishop is a
bit more secure so maybe C5 is more of
an idea for him
but I didn't want to think about uh
intricacies in a position where it's
going to be very difficult to figure out
you know the differences so I decided
anyway to quickly play Queen H5 and see
what happens
it ended up probably not being the best
move but also Queen G4 King AJ it's not
like I saw the next move so clearly like
what my plan is I wasn't sure I thought
basically my ideal setup is to
be able to put like a bishop somewhere
let's say on F4 to put my other work on
B1 and to put a queen on F3 but uh yeah
the setup is very hard to achieve and in
the game I didn't quite manage
well uh Jovi is very satisfying with
your answer thank you
hahaha
hey thank you for clarifying the
situation so here prepared Queen H5
against A5 but when A6 came he played It
Anyway same thing right okay good luck
in the playoffs